What just happened?
What did you do?
What's happening?
That, that's what
I'd like to know.
It's only
ever been about me.
About trying to be me.
We are each other.
A threat to one of us
is a threat to us both.
What are you doing?
Would you believe
I'm having a bad day?
It started when Bonnie
denied me my silence
-like immortality.
-Of course.
Because Katherine Pierce
can't be having
the good old
vampire-calibre mortality.
I deserved it.
I never had a graduation
or a prom
or, you know, a life.
But you did!
You have everything.
And it's not because
you're a good little girl
who deserves happiness,
it's because you stole mine!
I stole your happiness?
You killed my brother.
I'll admit, that was nasty.
I have nothing
But I'm about
to change that.
Kicking someone
while they're down,
classy till the end,
Katherine.
Your end.
How are you?
Good. Great.
You know, same as you.
Living my best life.
That is amazing, Sabrina.
Yeah, I know it is.
Except for this pool
of absolute darkness
in the minds that's gonna
consume Greendale
and the entire world,
if we don't stop it.
With a light that's bright
enough to banish it.
Like? Morningstar bright?
Yes.
And I can't do it alone.
But if the two of us
can invoke the Unholy Power
of our birthright,
it might work.
Will you help me?
We are each other.
A threat to one of us,
is a threat to us both.
I'm putting this down.
Okay?
It's okay.
-What are you?
-I don't want any trouble.
I don't know
what's happening,
I would just like you
to leave my house, please.
You leave this house.
In fact, what are you
even doing here?
I live here.
I live here!
-I live here!
-Take it easy. Take it easy.
What's happening?
What's happening...
That's what
I'd like to know.
The only thing I know
is that I was upstairs
with my wife...
Hold on. Your wife?
And now I'm being attacked
by someone
who looks like me.
In a diaper.
Well, all I know...
is that I went to a spa,
I woke up in a grave,
and then I walked barefoot
for six hours...
to find,
whatever the fuck you are,
upstairs with my wife!
I woke up in a spa.
But then I went to work,
came home,
and now this...
-A spa.
-A spa...
Bette...
Dot...
You have to come with me.
Now.
You don't give the orders
in this house.
Dot, I know
you have mixed feelings.
You're thinking
of getting the surgery,
which I'll never allow.
'Cause you'd never
cut a girl in half
-would you, Dandy?
-Shut up!
Stop trying
to ruin everything!
How do you know, Dandy?
About the surgery?
I told you there will be
no secrets between us.
You read my diary.
I want to leave.
She can't leave
without Bette.
We're in love.
And love trumps everything.
Your mother said
the girls could go anytime.
Let's let them decide.
Bette? I know you love me.
Tell them you want to stay
and live forever in luxury
with me.
There's something wrong
with Dandy and you know it.
I'm sorry.
But I choose my sister.
Always.
We have to go.
That's the only trick
you ever pulled.
All our lives,
you wanted everyone to think
you were the cleverer one,
the big brain, but...
it's only
ever been about me.
About trying to be me.
You always thought
too small.
Not like you, right?
Lucifer the rebel.
Deciding you can do
a better job than Dad.
You know, I wonder
how you got that idea
in your head
in the first place.
Oh, right.
That's your play, is it?
Taking credit
for my failed rebellion.
Oh, by all means,
it's yours.
Now, you see,
that is the best part.
All I did
was plant the idea.
You're the one
who chose to do it.
You still get to keep
all the blame yourself.
Your lies are so tedious,
Michael.
Not as tedious
as your denial.
Because I'm not lying now,
brother,
and I think deep down
you are realising that.
And once you realise that,
you're gonna wonder...
maybe it wasn't
just the rebellion
that was my suggestion.
What else?
What about
your little sexcapade
in the garden or...
oh… your vacation
here to Earth?
That's impossible.
It was quite easy, actually.
All it took
was a little whisper here,
a carefully orchestrated
coincidence there,
and your pathological
self-absorption, of course,
voilà!
All your idea.
This is nuts.
We're in a void
in the body
of a White lady--
-Not a lady.
-Not a lady, darling.
Well, we are White.
Let's all say
White people things!
Billy Joel.
I found it on Etsy.
There was nowhere to park.
Did you refill the Britta?
I find this void
quite calming, actually.
It's like,
this time the Xanax took me.
Oh, I have the worst
stomach ache.
Dude, relax!
Here, let me see
if I can figure this out.
Wow, Eleanor
how'd you do that?
I don't know.
We're Janets now,
so I thought we'd have
some bitching Janet powers.
What just happened?
What did you do?
Sorry, I'm just trying
to help Chidi calm down--
the structural integrity
of this void
is already at risk.
You can't start randomly
conjuring up objects
or it might shatter
the void.
Yes, it might.
It might
make everything blow up
and we'll all
disappear forever.
So, stop it!
There you are!
We were so worried
about you guys.
Explain.
Well,
Mother Superior called.
Your disciplinary meeting
got pushed up,
so? I had to be you.
But never mind me.
Are you guys okay?
More or less.
There was a bit of a hitch.
Peter had to stay behind
to create a diversion.
Fiona, you can't feel bad
about this.
Yeah,
it really isn't your fault.
Then who's fault is it?
We're back! Merry Christ...
What the--
Who the--
What's going on?
I can explain everything.
Which one are you?
It's okay, Kev.
That's Margaret, not Fiona.
-Stacy?
-Yeah.
And that's Margaret?
-You sure?
-Let me prove it to you.
No, no, no.
Okay. It's you. Phew.
That was really strange.